bonjour à tous on s'approche du nombre
fatidique des 10 me oui la semoy par les
juges est bientôt 10 millions d'abonnés
c'est absolument incroyable pour fêter
ça j'ai décidé d'aller à votre rencontre
et comme internet n'a pas de frontières
je veux aller dépassé la frontière
française vous en pensez quoi c'est une
bonne idée ou pas si voix la saluer
alors c'est parti
[Musique]
le temps de transport n'est pas perdu
j'en profite pour faire des montages la
vidéo que vous avez peut-être déjà vu
sinon regardez là le dessin s'asseoir
tout à l'heure mais c'est déjà sorti
quand ça sortira bref c'était compliqué
[Musique]
un temps magnifique et ça c'est
appréciable
[Musique]
c'est tellement beau
et voilà c'est parti de mes 10 millions
d'abonnés par bientôt 10
[Musique]
en fait je sens les plus très très loin
puis mon petit land
manger des frites ça elles sont bonnes
ici par la légende raconte que c'est
très bien
j'ai l'impression que se joue le sens un
peu les pieds
c'est beau jour de ma vie je terminais
met toi bien que vous avez basé
en france est il dit vient monde y vient
une fois c'est pour alléger un offre
d'accord alors vous mais gentil gentil
bouge de là une fois voilà c'est ça
dégage
on va les rejoindre les abonnés pour le
meet up à bruxelles c'est par là
peut-être
mais c'est parti pour un mythomane
sociale
la cour des chaînes youtube ici est rien
à personne je suis sur youtube heures oh
merci beaucoup tu sais que je fans de
manga se recharge plus que youtube
heures je me suis dit c'est l'idéal pour
cloche je découvre un manga ou les
youtuber décède ça fait super plaisir
du fait ce voyage pour célébrer les 10
millions d'abonnés il fallait un
prétexte pouvoir rencontrer les gens un
petit peu partout dans le monde parce
que c'est pas trop de mauvaises idées
mais ceci non j'ai pas de plan b
oui
j'avoue je les regarde pas parce que ça
me procure un peu balèze mai quand j'ai
posté ma première vidéo je vais poster
pour voir si ça marchait en fait comme
quand on branche un grille-pain quoi ça
marche ça marche voilà j'ai fait pareil
je suis dit mais là on va s'amuser là
vous pouvoir faire tout et n'importe
quoi mais je pensais pas que ça allait
être devenir finalement mon quotidien
vous êtes jumeaux du coup vous envoyer
la photo ça suffira
on sent que ça leur a fait plaisir que
je passe ici à bruxelles il s'attendait
pas à 0 n'y croyais pas trop si c'est
important pour moi de vous rencontrer
dix millions c'est un chiffre dingues
mais ça reste un chiffre
c'est bien
ça mange pas de
pain qu'ils étaient infectés bien sûr
grandes abonnées c'est faux
et je vais acheter 10 kg de frites
accéder cadeau pour toi sur ce match
j'ai dit que j'étais à bruxelles et sur
twitter beaucoup on se fait insulter
parce qu'il faut dire bruxelles sas à un
bus de bruxelles c'est trippant à
bruxelles
on a tout fait pour ta côté une bière
belge j'adore le malt et ben c'est parti
et voilà on nous a conseillé la triple
carmélites sabrosa
multiples carmélites cette
réglementation à metz le style c'est un
entation jeudi à bruxelles figure toi ma
fille c'est pour ça qu'elle nous a
rejoint reynolds argent pour boire de la
bière c'est la barrière acheté le manoir
elle va tourner
mais moi 5 heures du matin si la
meilleur horaire pour être rude
deux ennemis j'espère
tellement de brouillard à bruxelles qu
on voit même pas l'avion
c'est bon on en prend l'avion
quand je commence à chercher les
destinations francophones que je pouvais
visiter là où je pouvais aller voir mes
abonnés saleh de plus en plus loin cinq
destinations viendront jamais mis les
pieds je me suis dit on part tous
quelque chose de lourd
on est dans le labyrinthe je tombe sur
des rues qui tombent sur des reculs
tombe sur des impasses de manière
aléatoire on devrait réussir à sortir
voilà voilà
voilà petit verdot a bola total je sois
gay maintenant
a envie du soleil
j'ai trompé jean michel tromper c'est
moi
eh ben j'ai l'impression que c'est parti
pour rencontrer mes abonnés marocain
on est sur du cimic
meilleur accueil de la planète je pense
oui et en fait ça sera la vidéo de
toutes les rencontres que je fais là ces
quelques jours vous êtes ma vidéo de 10
minutes
je voulais pas faire non plus un trop
gros me top parce que sinon je peux pas
discuter avec vous je me suis dit je
vais plutôt prendre un peu le temps avec
un peu moins de gens mais des gens qui
sont à fond parce que quand on discutait
avec vous ça fait chaud au coeur un
petit cadeau c'est le plus gros choix de
photos
est ce normal
elle a repris leur foncer on écoute on
que les langes c'est vrai parce qu'il ya
des sous titres à bâle doit avoir un
français un peu
selon français à moi c'est pas le
meilleur 6 et un roumain qui lui apprend
le français on est mal et on romanenko
sata plus c'est super aussi dans mes
prochaines vidéos je suis obèses ou 10
ans en farsi dans ce contexte
[Musique]
saga des questions qui reviennent
souvent et en fait on se rend compte que
n'importe quel pays où ils sont ils ont
les mêmes intérêts ils ont les mêmes
questionnements du coup il ya un truc
qui rapproche en fait toutes ces
personnes on pense pas créer du lien en
fait quand juste divertir ça c'est d'un
corps
non c'est le moment de partir on est
resté à peine plus de 24 heures à
casablanca
c'est à dire aussi une nouvelle
destination
[Musique]
je suis accueilli par le grand gibier
salut je viens deux et youtuber de
profession exactement youtuber suisse
vient de montrer un petit peu le savent
il exactement
bien sûr mais pour tous ensemble merci
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression d'appeler quelqu'un en
fait ouais la serbie a communiqué dans
les montagnes de balai à bazeilles c'est
un système de communication voix là
parce que c'est l'ancêtre de l'iphone
non pas du tout
china alors chin qui l'accueille
je viens demander ça fait dix ans qu'il
est sûr chantal météo si ça fait bientôt
dix ans après la crise en février sa
part disant ouais et tu te rends compte
que tu as 10 millions d'abonnés non en
fait à chaque fois que tu sur une vidéo
tu poses pas ça j'évite de me dire
qu'ils sont 10 millions je me disait
long son sang et ils sont chauds jack
est déjà bien le savoir mais comme je
devenais actuellement moi je te suis
j'ai suis là je nourris de surveiller
les statistiques des fous moi la
pression un peu donc 9 millions 995
1493 peut-être on va passer ensemble les
10 millions je crois que je passe les 10
millions en suisse je sais pas ça
vachement
étape en suisse à genève et y'a du monde
ici
les ennemis la république
c'est vrai que j'ai passé un peu de
temps dans la ville j'espère quoi les
gens courent tout le temps dans cette
vision croyable
je pourrais je sais pas pourquoi
l'actrice de visionner ici les français
qui sont venus envahir les lions et les
a repoussés en chemise de nuit et tout
avec des casseroles toulouse patois
c'est mon grand père
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression de sacrifier
la dépression on est à combien on est là
c'est donc quelques
sous la pression il fallait pas me le
dire ça
il manque 100 personnes mais non une
seule personne dont tirait la triche
50 personnes ça va t'attendre personne
du coup bombe maintenant peut-être que
tu manges las des abonnés à la fin et je
me retrouve avec trois abonnés dix
personnes cinq personnes
nominaux et la famille comme ça va trop
vite c'est un truc de malade j'étais pas
prêt
alors qu'est-ce que
[Musique]
ça fait la pression c'est vrai
ce qu on l arrivée au 10 millions un peu
plus tard non vraiment une semaine dix
jours est en fête
en fait non mais on y est déjà et
et je suis super content d'eux
voilà je sais pas quoi dire
[Musique]
oh
pourquoi j'ai mis ma première vidéo je
pensais pas que que autant de gens
allaient nous faire confiance en tout
cas soit curieux sur ce que je fais donc
voilà merci beaucoup merci beaucoup de
faire confiance d'être très nombreux ça
fait très plaisir parce que ça veut dire
que c'est pas dans le vide ce que je
fais et à touques est sûr c'est que j'ai
hâte de fêter ça avec avec plein de gens
et d'ailleurs à des rencontres et du
coup demandant une autre destination et
faire plein d'autres projets aussi est
ce que c'est que le début du tribe
[Musique]
vie très courte dans l'avion mais
c'est parra puisqu'on arrive jusqu'à 9
degrés du coup on pardonne tout pourquoi
je vous montre à poil là
j'adore tes vidéos
photos on y prend fin je voulais que ce
soit un grand moment non je dépasse les
10 millions d'abonnés est resté à paris
on va dans mon bureau ou quoi c'était
pas forcément bon moment je suis bougé
si je bouge il faut je rencontre des
gens j'ai rencontré des gens je verrai
jamais rencontrés je veux voir des
cultures que j'ai jamais vu mettre les
pieds là où j'ai jamais mis les pieds me
suis dit allons loin allons au chaud au
froid là où il ya des abonnés la mener
un petit peu partout
vous êtes à 15 heures on va trouver la
crème solaire vous êtes sympas les
maliens on a ensuite âge c'est savent
dans quoi
en informatique hra pharma tic c'est ici
que ça se passe j'ai l'impression que
c'est un peu déçu merci beaucoup y
faisant
venir à la réunion pour un stage
informatique
moitié des belges il cependant
c'est quoi cette température n'était pas
prêt et moi j'étais pas très haut
le jeune homme aux 10 millions d'abonnés
pour plein de gens ça va être la course
à avoir le plus d'abonnés mais je pense
que c'est pas forcément la bonne
démarche si vous faites ça par intérêt
pour dire tiens c'est à la mode tiens je
vais faire des vues tiens je vais faire
de la thune tiens je vais être célèbre
ça va se voir et si vous avez un puck au
fond de vous vous avez envie de créer
vous en raconter quelque chose foncez
garder le plaisir partagé ça aussi c'est
avec des amis et franchement ça va
cartonner
[Musique]
je sais plus exactement où on est on est
à la réunion c'est sûr mais faut que
c'est dur à les aider
et tout et tout les images commencent à
se mélanger
vols et destinations les pays différents
thés ou là
bouger autant comme ça de changer autant
de destinations ce breton j'ai jamais
fait ça
[Musique]
je me rends compte que j'ai déjà
parcouru beaucoup dans mon voyage et que
j'ai parcouru aussi beaucoup bas depuis
10 ans sur internet quoi je me dis nous
arrêtons pas il reste une destination
est bas allons-y en france 11 heures de
vol
c'est parti pour cette heure de vol
jusqu'à faire du coup de 18 heures de
vol au total
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va faire un bonhomme de neige il
faudrait que je trouve de la neige j'ai
l'impression que j'ai trouvé
vous pouvez remarquer ça ne marche pas
bon après une heure de travail je
terminais mon bonhomme noël alors ça
vous plaît voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai
réussi à faire en 45 minutes
ah ouais bull
justement partir je pensais surtout aux
abonnés que j'ai rencontré qu'est ce
qu'ils ont pensé de ça et si vous êtes
vous sûr de voir est ce qu'il préfère
pas squeeze
un peu d'appréhension je
voulais pas que ma vie deux des dix
millions à ressemble à toutes les autres
vidéos que j'ai fait ma chaîne j'aime
bien aussi faire des trucs sont un petit
peu différent c'est pour ça que depuis
quelques années je fais des sketches un
peu différent des courts métrages
j'ai sorti une bd ça peut prendre plein
de formes et tout ça
depuis dix ans ça n'a pas changé je crée
toujours plein de trucs ya juste
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus de monde
qui me suivent
mais au fond 1
ressent de faire ce que j'ai toujours su
faire avoir des idées et les mettre en
scène comme je peux avec une caméra web
bien sûr on est aussi
là je vais rejoindre thomas gautier
youtube heure de montréal qui fait des
vidéos depuis très très longtemps comme
moi
[Musique]
oui merci pour l'accueil dans cette
magnifique ville de thompson montréal
j'aime beaucoup c'est essentiellement
basé sur les variantes
prenez place vous avez vous
rejoint les jeunes locuteurs culturel la
bac aux enfants dans votre bois a redit
la bac s dans le fond de la boîte à bois
ça veut dire dans tout ça ça veut dire
dans ce
suivi par le représentant la nation ils
se disent avoir des coups tu as mangé
ses avoirs il apporte de l'expérience à
acquérir tentant des coups tu as mangé
encore apprendre
[Applaudissements]
le bac
la phase 4 la fermeture
l'année apparaît dans chaque escale
expression française fais tu pourrais ne
pas comprendre et du monde au balcon du
haut d'un balcon et du monde au balcon
du monde à la messe non c'est une fille
qui a un grand décolleté
juste aujourd'hui vous pas vous déranger
ou deux peut-être un troll j'ai une
autre fan aussi j'aimerai savoir
que deux pattes j'ai bien fait de la
marque oui je n'ai qu'à trois
sets ça pas mal de gens qui est dans la
région devant une maison de retraite
espace rien vraiment rien
est à 48 heures je t'ai envoyé devant
les pieds dans l'eau
à la recherche des poissons temps qui
courent
faut savoir que ma valise ne ressemble à
rien j'ai des tongs des maillots de bain
et ensuite des doudounes des gants c'est
n'importe quoi alors effet shoah
actuellement moins sept degrés ce qui
est bien quand allons tous les membres
de mon corps vont s'arracher
j'ai vu ma bière belge j'ai mangé mon
chocolat suisse j'ai mangé mon orgueil
saucisses à la réunion
merci la réunion oh là là
j'ai eu un petit à gino maroc et puis la
poussée d'un de montréal alors j'ai
demandé sur twitter quel restaurant je
vais choisir vous pouvez voir que c'est
un 50/50 parfait du coup on va choisir
poutine ville parce que le nom et marron
la poutine de montréal pommes de terre
fromage un peu de viande et une petite
sauce brune des familles
ta grand bruit oui
voilà poutine vous savez tout du moins
visiblement je n'ai pas de secret c'est
très bien c'est la première poutine
c'est très bon je n'ai plus faim depuis
tu savais que j'étais attendu
dans ces villes mais on n'arrive pas à
imaginer les gens alors vu des visages
en revue des sourires alors fait des
câlins de recevoir des cadeaux de fait
des tchèques des selles filles on
immortalise ça je peux pas l'imaginer
c'est vraiment moi qui vais le chercher
il fallait que je fasse ce petit voyage
pour me rendre compte
c'est la fin je suis tellement triste
qu'on arrive à cette dernière rencontre
d'abonnés 10 millions de ses incroyables
un penny croire et vous rendez ça très
concret quand je vous vois je me dis
voilà c'est des vrais personnes des
vrais gens c'est pas que des pseudos ce
sans vous je fais pas grand chose merci
de me faire confiance
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
et voilà
on est dix millions de propriétaires de
ce bouton c'est un bouton qu'on partage
tous sauf que c'est moi qui la garde je
suis la maman c'est plein de sens pour
ce que je fais le plus maintenant parce
que dix ans sur internet et ça signifie
aussi la fin de cette vidéo la fin de ce
petit périple c'était dingue voyager
autant de rencontres et autant de gens
de gens différents de culture différente
de pays différents c'est important pour
moi de prendre le temps à un moment de
partir dix jours rencontre les gens
comme ça vous abonner que je jamais
l'occasion de rencontrer et je suis très
content de m'être enrichi de toutes ces
rencontres
comment je pourrais me dire tiens
finalement c'est chiant
finalement c'est pas épanouissants
tellement c'est pas intéressant
peut pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on sait tous qu'on peut dire ça quand on
a dit mme d'abonnés mais sait-on jamais
bonnes toi
[Musique]